why do I answer the same question over
and over and over again I'll tell you
why so got a great question for my loyal
youtube viewers love you guys Raquel
English wrote in the same Evan it amazes
me that people continually ask the same
questions all the time they need to go
back and watch all your old videos
you've answered these same questions a
million times humans take forever to
grasp concepts teehee Macau so Raquel
thanks for the question and I'm feeling
the love you know I'm feeling the you
know you don't want me waste my time
answering the same questions over and
over again and people should have more
respect and I apart you agree with you
and so what I've been doing recently is
if somebody asks you a question I feel
like I've answered over and over and
over again I used to send them links and
say hey check out this video see what
helps you and if not then then ask me a
new question I'll and I'll help guide
you through it and now I'm I'm not doing
the effort because I get so many
comments as it's crazy it's crazy just
to keep up and respond with a happy face
now I will tell people just look for
this on my channel so somebody's ready
how do I don't know what my passion is I
don't know how to find it I'll tell them
look for the Explorer video on my
channel and if if you know they take two
seconds to do that search then they'll
find a great video and if they don't
then are they yeah now we're going to
have the gusto and gumption to go and
start their own business so I've been in
a little bit of that but here's the main
reason why I get the same questions and
I'll take some of them over and over
again it's because people have a mindset
an environment that holds them back this
is a big challenge you know a lot of
entrepreneurs myself included didn't
grow up with entrepreneurs in the family
didn't grow up with a family that
encouraged them to get into business and
didn't tell them how to do it may not
have friends or anybody else they can
look to in their network to teach them
how to be an entrepreneur and that was
me and
as a result you develop habits to
develop a mindset and you have this
environment that holds you where you are
prevents you from doing great things in
the world of business and to change that
is hard it doesn't happen in one video
right it's not just giving them a
strategy and then boom their life has
changed that can happen for some people
but more often than not it's the
continual reminders that that's what
starts to make the change its its hand
holding people along the way and helping
them realize that hey here are some
changes you can make in your life an
example say is learning a language if
you want to learn Japanese and say one
day you'll earn 10 words right you're
watching YouTube you to learn 10 words
but see you never go back to watching
the YouTube video nobody in your family
speaks Japanese nobody in your
surrounding speaks Japanese and while
you may try to practice and try to
remember over time you're just going to
forget those 10 words and so the same
thing happens with entrepreneurship
right you may learn something in the
video you may try to apply it but
because nothing in your environment and
in the minds of you that you have
doesn't help you really leverage that
really strongly you fall back to your
old habits you fall back to that same
column the that's a question about and
so it's a consistent push it's the
consistent videos right that the people
who watch the channel every day and get
that little bit of extra boost and a
little bit of extra strategies to help
them grow and sometimes you need to hear
the message over and over and over again
I try to use different words I try to
use different stories I'm not always the
greatest of doing that so for those of
you watching thank you so much for your
patience but I think having that
consistent message helps people who may
feel down on themselves may have heard
the message before but having that
little energy shot again helps pick
themselves up because their environment
doesn't support them and finally I make
these videos for me you know i wish i
had this
that was the younger entrepreneur
because I almost quit I almost went and
took a job and I wish there was
something like this around what I was
young and getting started and full of
doubt and wasn't having success with my
company I really wanted something that
was a dealing boost with information and
motivation so I make these videos for my
younger self and then make the videos
for all the people who are like me back
then and who can now benefit from that
knowledge and motivation and I'm just
super honored and happy that you guys
are joining me on this journey and that
you're finding it to be helpful and
useful and your growing business so
that's why I do it that's why I answer
questions keep asking them but I'll try
to keep mentioning them for you thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe I don't see you soon